okay life is good I have more followers
new opponents that worked out playing
logic what's g3 someone wanted caro-kann
I'm playing a Carolyn against g3 not
sure why it's by h5 how can these moves
be related 996 g6 this is actually
reasonable now there should be two and
now this move yeah I don't mind this
position it's some kind of new type of
opening a 97 like Bishop f5 I want to
play e5 soon efore I'll move back
maybe b5 or maybe I'll just move back
cuz if this all push let's attack
I'll light one connect four let's play
play this move I have a feeling there's
gonna be opportunities for the pin and
win yet again
mmm let's take
it's close very close
I'm just gonna sack a night for no
reason cuz why not I win oh I've sacking
another night
knocking another night but pin and win
pinning right the similar tactic the
previous game in this game it's a little
bit more questionable because White has
three minor pieces for the Queen and the
pieces I do have on the board or pretty
garbage but it's okay
pinin win d5 is gonna fall all man this
is slightly traumatic
I want a Castle queenside
well I could pin the night to the c2
pond oh three away three followers away
I should I should pay attention to
multiple things 99.98% 19,000 Oh Fork
there's a fork in the position but
there's 92 it's a problem I could Castle
queenside castling queenside we trade
everything I lose a pawn still I don't
want to miss a twenty thousand okay I
have an idea I'm gonna play this force
92 and then the problem won't be
attacked as much and then all queenside
castle which simultaneously puts a rock
on g8 and on Kenzie Bishop to defend the
pawn there's also this line which means
a bishop so now white only has two minor
pieces for the Queen
but still some initiative oh wow what a
move
that's a nasty move
hmm I could take I just take maybe I
should take the rook because this is
coming
take the rook
and then take again
and then maybe I want to play g5 + g5 is
interesting all but then rook takes g5
play f5 mm-hmm nothing looks so great
it's yf5 I can still legally castle
we're in an endgame that's so funny
bishop there let's play this I can't
leave with Castle yet his D it's
controlled but someday my king and rook
has have still not moved I won't play F
for the night the Knights coming in
let's play this move now there goes my
castling rights I was so excited to
castle on that in game I should probably
focus on not flagging we hit it 20,000
woohoo ok I can't I can't mess this up
but I'm messing it up check Huntington
fall for mates of 12 seconds ok this is
for all 20,000 of you beautiful
followers I'll try not to let you people
down let's play b5 I mean it's hard when
I'm down a bishop for nothing I'm trying
to meet my opponent ha
thanks for the bits why okay I have to
go for a dirty flag young children close
your eyes
Congrats Eric thank you
no my rook dirty flag 20,000 followers
it's a miracle
thank you so much everyone
that's for all 20,000 of you might see a
thank you so much and you too
and just last year who was the 20,000
for the most recent follower was I can't
even find it cuz everyone shared the
space between the space between you were
the 20,000th follower I think just blast
her thanks so much for the song what a
game I was in nasty game a KD 707 thanks
for the thousand bits contact buffalo so
many people that wasn't does I'm sorry
it's my opponent for so much nastiness
the dirty pits the next milestone is
thirty thirty thousand twenty five
thousand or twenty thousand and one
thanks so much everyone do I end it
I just retire now oh the game wasn't
nasty game well I didn't hit 2600 but I
hit I hate 20,000
yeah thanks everyone um I'll probably
put this on YouTube even though it
wasn't the highest quality game
thank you everyone two people on twitch
and YouTube for viewing and for joining
in the chats and lurking and liking and
commenting and subscribing and cheering
yeah it's it's very gratifying to see
how many people have been watching and
supported last time
thanks so much master master all so
people on YouTube stay tuned for more
content you can subscribe on YouTube and
you can follow on Twitch now wash-up
says might see it